[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] think you're dealing with this
Monday morning
it's Monday morning [ __ ] he who
hesitates masturbates it's the week of
my first special 25 years and somebody
finally said hey let's put this
[ __ ] out there let these
[ __ ] know what they've been
missing and guess what I'm ready I'm
prepared and thanks to you [ __ ]
forget about it I'm about to go in there
on Saturday and rip those [ __ ]
alive uncle Joey here it's a beautiful
[ __ ] day to be alive it's a beautiful
dentistry smoke grief it's a beautiful
day to [ __ ] write your goes down who
gives a [ __ ] about Trump in the [ __ ]
hog it don't matter you've still gotta
get up and get a gun and go up and swing
dick with three [ __ ] hands every day
who gives a [ __ ] about all that but
enough with the chitty-chat uncle Joey
it was some tremendous [ __ ] weeds coming
from perennial little Paris og and they
should hear Oh
oh my god I smoked some of that [ __ ] yes
I passed out for like 19 [ __ ] hours
oh nothing like a nice little booty
loops on a [ __ ] Monday before you got
it what they stabbed a [ __ ] than
that me I'm saying it's one thing they
got arrested but there's nothing he got
arrested when you got two joints under
you belt trust me I got arrest the hell
ecstasy one time
un-fuckin'-believable fingerprinting I'm
feeling [ __ ] in princey and [ __ ] you
don't think but anyway who gives a [ __ ]
I'm ready to go to church tonight eight
o'clock I got you today I'm back that's
the [ __ ] fool with a half weeks up
[ __ ] bag my back is [ __ ]
tremendous I got the blood test last
week I got the piss test I did
everything sometimes you gotta go to a
doctor listen I have insurance if you
ain't got a [ __ ] push it to the hilt
I'm saying
and besides when you gotta show us that
means you could smoke big [ __ ] reefer
and I'd have to worry about little
things but everything's good I have no
[ __ ] problems tomorrow night I'm at
the store the last one on a run through
Thursday me and we had have two [ __ ]
beautiful Chicago we're gonna hook up
with Pete the Greek Thursday night and
mine John a little [ __ ] Italian and I
beef with the sausage forget about I'll
be farting up a [ __ ] storm Friday I'm
gonna hook up with my man Josh Passini
over at Ted planet Chicago he's gonna
teach me a few things and then Saturday
we got to [ __ ] shows all the shows
are sold out Friday and sadness tears
they help me [ __ ] see you
Thursday Thursday so our big night Lisa
would be ready stars explosives Gorilla
Biscuits
quaaludes lemons roar is 714 expressed
some rednecks [ __ ] toenails we're
going deep
by the way happy for Christopher
Columbus Day what're you doing - if you
don't have the day off y'all discover
yourself a new job that gives you the
[ __ ] day off if you know what I'm
saying beside that that's a burn up
since [ __ ] 4:30 can pop to do right
my goal is listening to tape from [ __ ]
of a weekend the mistakes I made in
Columbus and I got a refund go out then
we do them again tomorrow night
and that's it that's what all about it's
about failing and picking yourself up
and stabbing [ __ ] in the
eyeballs when you make a backup that's
it you're gonna go down you're gonna
[ __ ] fail what do you gonna do I
don't give a [ __ ] I got one foot in the
grave on a banana peel I'm content to
you understand me always remember greed
and patience can't look together if you
get that one down you'll be fine the
rest of our life
that's nice right there let's do another
ball what the [ __ ] you doing with your
life you don't say cause you know I
ain't talking [ __ ] with my life
anyway you [ __ ] filthy [ __ ] to
give some shoutouts to my people whose I
backed away
Timmy jr. my main man [ __ ] what a
boxer
share it Bobby shower down there [ __ ]
Austin holdin it down with a new
podcasters [ __ ] I got my man man Tommy
[ __ ] he stuff always doing this
thing although they down appear gnarly
would [ __ ] smacking [ __ ] and I
got all used cuz without you
[ __ ] I'd be doing nothing Nana
you guys watch me we have a good time
together we smoke dope was--that's the
Shamy we smoke real doctor I'm not like
these [ __ ] people listen leave me the
[ __ ] alone I'd rather be running solo
looking Lillis we live like doctors
together
it's [ __ ] seven something was smokin
dope on sac
I will dope nothing how we do these [ __ ]
oh my god I take two heads up such a
team get the [ __ ] out of it I'm blasting
indica I've [ __ ] 6:35 in the am I
[ __ ] black doing a porno just shove
it into fluff and dirty white I was
taken you tattooed filthy [ __ ] animal
anyway it's good to be alive
just good to have your [ __ ] together on
a Monday and that's it I'm getting older
I'm getting wiser but who gives a [ __ ] I
got one for the grave one I've been an
appeal I'm already a [ __ ] go every
day I come off the [ __ ] jump like
it's my last [ __ ] day on this damn
that's the bid then I get this little
[ __ ] reef take it me that push over
the mountain who's gonna stop me who the
fuzz and they stopped me [ __ ]
[ __ ] I got stopped you is you I
realized that when I got out of [ __ ]
prison
that's the only person who could stop
you it's you you [ __ ] now they have to
shoot me in the [ __ ] head shoot me in
the leg with a tranquilizer they have to
beat me like Rodney King yeah
and to do what to do what you always
meant to [ __ ] do
they can't stop your dog so keep hanging
away you little [ __ ] buddy hey get
the [ __ ] out of here
you break out of that [ __ ] boy I got
there like [ __ ] Michael Jackson there
with those six [ __ ] [ __ ] brothers
and you'll be fine okay take that got it
back from you Uncle Joe we got a [ __ ]
Monday morning Christopher Columbus Day
Italians are jumping up and down and
that's sitting at that I'll see you
[ __ ] tonight ready the clock to
Churchill what's happening now or
tomorrow at eight o'clock and two copies
book another room or Thursday [ __ ]
Friday Saturday's Chicago or they know
[ __ ] us I'll see you in Paris before
some of the house will do one [ __ ]
thing and that's it and that's that
uncle Joey loves you see you
[ __ ] tonight oh great they
don't let nobody [ __ ] with you keep your
[ __ ] head out of your phone and watch
to see what's going on understand me
don't worry ain't nobody Trump they got
to protect you he'll any other protect
you you gotta [ __ ] protect you
[ __ ] get up see you [ __ ]
tonight be square the church always
happening now
love you [ __ ]